DDC hearing aids I think that's actually
going to be a big deal and they're
profitable
I mean I'm just turning you on yeah they
were yeah
[Laughter]
oh my God how far how far away from the
coast did they live
for the inland
[Music]
all right we're here Steph Smith's here
one of the all-time all-time favorite
guests uh this is I think appearance
number six so if you love this one go go
listen to the other five that stuff's
done Steph's is great because she brings
a dossier I can't even call it a
document it should be on Google
dossier.com because it is a 15 page
document of Trends ideas
uh small like you know observations that
might you know half ideas that might
become something
which makes you essentially the perfect
MFM guest um and you're also cool and
fun to hang out with so thank you for
coming back yeah good to be here every
time I come on I get way more nervous
than any other appearance because you
guys hyping up like that Sean do you
know how I met Steph uh no tell me the
story I will forever take credit
for Steph Smith's career it has nothing
to do no matter what I do no matter how
hard she works no matter how smart she
is it's all of me I've I I'm a
completely so basically she had this
blog it's still is it Steph Smith dot IO
yeah it was a really good blog and she
had this headline and the headline was
to be great just be good consistently is
that it stuff basically uh what was it
what is it exactly yeah it's like how to
be great question Mark just be great
repeatedly be good repeatedly oh yes be
good and I was like I dm'd her I was
like Steph this is the best headline
I've ever read this is a really good
headline like we're launching this thing
called Trends do you want to join us and
she was like ah maybe and I was like
look come work for us for a couple years
and I have a feeling you're gonna like
go and leave us and that's totally cool
come do like a tour of Duty now
it's been about a year and a half for me
a year since she's left she's uh at
Andreessen Horowitz one of the uh
biggest VC firms in the world how is
that going it's going great yeah we just
hired a producer which is nice because
for a while I was kind of hacking it
together myself but yeah I feel like the
podcast finally is taking off and we're
trying a bunch of different formats it's
actually like I feel like I'm easing
into it I'm finally having fun like when
I listened to my first million you can
tell you guys talk about it's like the
best job in the world I'm finally easing
into that which is nice what's it like
working there I mean when I think about
working there I think of like uh like
the TV show billions you know like it's
just like fun all the time but is
it just normal company I mean
it just like is it more normal of a job
than I think or is it as spectacular as
I would imagine I mean it's kind of both
because day to day it's totally normal
because you're just doing your job
you're just doing work do you go into an
office are you remote um I'm remote they
do have offices I go on every so often
just because I started working remotely
I a year into my career and so for the
last like eight years or so I've never
had an office and so it's like a novelty
for me everyone else is looking sick of
the office and I'm like oh candy bars
you're like oh you just sit here all day
wow yeah you can't leave this box I know
it's crazy I'm like oh it called like
how special I think uh the way Sam talks
about like when his wife Sarah worked at
Facebook and he's like and you know when
you work at a place you just sort of get
used to everything and you kind of
optimize for convenience and so like oh
they're all hands meetings on I can
either go down to the cafeteria and
listen to it or they have like a
streaming option because there's plays
all around the world like all right
whatever I'll just stream it from my
desk yeah that's easier I'll eat my
salad here and Sam was like no you need
to go sit front row with a pen and pad
and when he says any questions you need
to like jump out of your chair and ask
them a question every single week until
he invites us over for dinner like that
was basically Sam's like master plan
until you're his best friend I kind of
think you should be doing the same thing
like what's the point of working at
Andreessen Horowitz friends
unless you're just like at the office
every day just waiting for some like
awesome Mark Andreessen moment to happen
or just like you're there when he just
yells at somebody and uh it just goes
off or like you know they're doing a
blood you know like the the 12 year olds
coming to give them blood and like
you're like yes this is the weirdness I
came here for is like it's like every
it's like every movie ever where there's
like the big boss at the conference
table and it's like who what channel
let's put this together and then the
manager is like oh what about guys bring
your guy here let me talk to that person
or like Mark andreessen's gonna say like
you know who thought to do this the
number on this is Blake could be blank
and you say actually sir it's six four
seven three what did you say it's six
four seven three because uh this come
with me yeah it's like for six weeks
I've been leaving crumbs in the kitchen
to see if anybody would clean it up and
finally somebody did let's pull up the
security footage it was Steph Smith
you're promoted you're at the top now
right these are the fanfic this is what
I think is gonna happen if you but you
just got to be there I can't believe
you're not there every day you should be
every day in the office that's the real
upside of your job it's not your salary
it's that you can go hang out with some
of the smartest people in the world but
you got to do the hangout part not the
like just when we're on calls then I
gotta hover yeah you're right I gotta
hover around the office just like you do
on the internet you gotta lurk you gotta
be able to think about this if you told
like 21 year old you that you would be
in this position and you'd be like would
you just stay home and just kind of do
your own thing or would you like go be
there and hang out and lurk and like you
know just be serendipitous about like
what's gonna happen you know the 21 year
old you would be like Oh I'm definitely
going in I'm going to meet these people
I'm going to see what's up uh but I
think it's easy later to be like casual
about it yeah I gotta Embrace I feel
like Sam if you're in the office you'd
like go up to someone grabbing a snack
and be like hey what's up how's it going
and I'm like so awkward I'm like you
need to be romantic comedy bumping into
everybody and dropping all the papers
that you're holding and then being like
let's clean this up together not even
for the romance just to like you create
a little like intersection between you
and me and these people
when I was at twitch where we got
acquired
um I literally I even told people there
openly I was like I'm not here to do my
job I was like I'm gonna find whatever
the most interesting things are
happening here and I'm just gonna go be
in those meetings and do that like
you're not gonna but that works right
like and it works differently like
you're friends with Emmett yeah me and
Emmett yo got I got to I was like this
is the most interesting guy in this
building so anytime it's like you need
to go talk to you know Jerry on the
fourth floor no I think I'm just gonna
hang out in them it's I'm just gonna
stay in the meeting like we do the
meeting with them everybody gets up and
leaves and I'm just gonna stay there on
my laptop next group walks in I'm still
there I'm just gonna hang out and see
what happens like No One's Gonna say
anything or uh I remember when ninja got
poached to like the top streamer on
Twitch got poached and there was like I
know there's secret meetings happening
about like what should we do should we
like counter offer or what is like a
code red moment and there's always but I
wasn't in those
so I just wrote up a plan and I sent it
to like the three top Executives I was
like here's the plan for Ninja I know
I'm not even on the team but then they
were like attend this meeting tonight at
8pm and I was like I'm in I got into the
cool by just like not doing my job
and uh that's that's my recommendation
to you if you're gonna be around these
like 9 000 IQ people
that's the real upside of your job don't
do your actual job do the job of hanging
out speaking of speaking of which stuff
are they actually do you think that the
talent there are they actually
significantly smarter than any other uh
like pretty decent tech company
um I would say yes I I would say I've
worked at I mean not that many companies
but it's a direct shot at you Sam I
really ever worked for you and
Marketplace
typically like at least five five
companies where I've been a full-time
employee and I would say
this job was a lot of checkers and now
I'm playing chess
what the do those Jesus know about
newsletters well you guys have something
that's the bigger this uh you were like
oh I get nervous for this more than
anything else I'm curious do you feel
nervous when you are in one of these
like a16z like whatever meetings like
are you like oh these are yeah these are
like people I used to follow on Twitter
and like that and now I'm in this
room
yeah definitely I mean I think there's
an element too where I don't represent
the company running this podcast but in
a way the podcast is like an asset to
the firm and I'm like they hired I mean
I'm glad they did but they hired a 29
year old who like candidly feels a
little out of place amongst these people
who have been you know like Mark
Andreessen basically like invented the
Internet like he created the first
browser or the the wide skill browser
and so I'm like I do feel sometimes a
little out of place but I feel like I'm
a year in I'm getting used to it I think
you should give yourself more credit uh
you're cooler than everybody I've met at
a16c so you know I think I think they're
lucky to have you as far as I'm
concerned I'm gonna bring in one of
those Nick Gray name tags that says
cooler than you Sean thinks I'm cooler
than everyone here exactly this is why I
knew she was a good hire because I was
like
in my head I was like oh she doesn't she
doesn't realize how good she is
like this is a deal I got him
she doesn't know yet
um Steph where do you want to go from
here
um let's just start with the first idea
so this one I think is really
interesting
um because right now I think a lot of
people listening know that there's this
issue with commercial real estate all
these Office Buildings you know are up
for sale or at least people are leaving
and like the highest level of like
vacancy ever basically uh and especially
in cities like San Francisco where I
think there's like 35 vacancy and going
up as soon as people's leases roll off
as soon as they can get out of their
lease so they will so it's like uh you
know it's just a it's a disaster
so what is this thing so a lot of people
think okay well then let's go change
let's swap those that commercial real
estate for homes apartments Etc that
makes sense but I think there's this
huge opportunity for fractional real
estate so click one of where it says see
here click one of those and tell me what
you see
all right sure you want to go I'm
describing I'll describe it so it look
it's something called Temple immersive
and it basically looks like a yoga class
of some kind it's like dimly lit candles
looks like a hot yoga class but then on
the roof is this like crazy visual where
it looks like you're in the forest and
the whole thing just looks super cool
where do you think this is like what is
this building
I mean I have no idea this looks I mean
this looks like the lobby of an office
building in a way it's like huge but
they make it look like a temple yeah so
this is a club during the night a
nightclub so I mean this is just one
example obviously of where real estate
is used from what Saturday Friday
Saturday Sunday that's it from like 7 00
P.M to 2 A.M and then throughout the
week it's not used at all and so the
thing that I found fascinating I went to
this called Temple immersive in San
Francisco and I talked to the woman they
just opened up and I was like how'd you
find this like did you reach out to a
bunch of clubs and they were like no the
club reached out to us like I guess it
makes sense but this club has just all
this real estate that's being unused and
I was just thinking about what other I
guess one this could be applied
elsewhere right like in any City someone
can go contact a bunch of clubs link
them up with yoga studios Pilates
studios Etc
um but then I was also thinking what
else could this real estate be used for
and another Trend that's been taking off
is Rage rooms have you guys heard of
Rage rooms no but I like smash it right
yeah yeah there's there's one in SF as
well
um but basically
they're losing their jobs yeah it's
called like the Range Rover Market
Street Market yeah
the city is the rage room yeah CBS is
doing a Rebrand
okay what is this rage room so
people will literally go and yeah like
Sean said you just smash it so like
they'll give you a bunch of plates
they'll give you like old electronics
they'll give you stuff and I think
depending on what you choose you pay a
different amount and you just get a
session in this like empty room and you
just get to smash stuff which you just
don't get to do in normal life
um and so I was thinking I was like you
know not just do yoga studio but a lot
of this real estate like go convert like
a club during the week to like a rage
room people we have um
I always thought like these little
things were it wouldn't be that
interesting but we have this member of
Hampton and he's tweeting about it his
name's Raleigh Williams I was just going
to bring him home yep dude so he he I
think he's in Utah and he created uh
it's like I don't know I thought escape
room was like a brand but I think it's
also like the style uh and so he created
like a version of an escape room and
what did he do Sean he sold it for about
30 million dollars he created a business
he sold it for 26 million dollars and
what he says is
basically he's at a law firm and he
doesn't love his job and he's like okay
should I do something else like what
should I do he reads an article that
talks about the uh how lucrative Escape
rooms were this is back in 2015 when the
Escape rooms were really like just sort
of like the new trend it was the new new
like Froyo basically so he he looks it
up he finds out how much money these
make and he's like okay
I think this is a good business but I
don't have enough money to go build it
out
but in the true entrepreneurial Spirit
he doesn't let the lack of resources
stop him he becomes resourceful he's
like all right can I build an escape
room inside this like abandoned bus so
he goes by the buys this uh 1984
Bluebird bus and he converts the inside
into an escape room and now he's got an
escape room on Wheels he could drive it
up to companies offices and do the
corporate off-site right there and so uh
it wasn't perfect in the sense that like
if it was a hot day or a cold day it
kind of sucked to be inside of it but
other than that it was like this like
super efficiency is he ever allowed him
to get real like cash flow going I think
he said like the bus itself was making
like
um five or ten Grand a month of like you
know free cash flow and so he starts
opening up more and so he builds out his
first real one he opens
um you know five six more or whatever
then he starts adding to the back of the
so there's like real estate so he's
getting the real estate with the escape
room and he's getting more space and he
created a trampoline park and an ax
throwing things so basically just like
this kind of like out of home
entertainment is what we call like this
category and so he just bundles these
together and uh over that period of like
2015 to 2020-ish he's uh built this
thing up and then he starts selling them
off so he's selling off uh you know in
chunks of pieces and he basically said
that he made 26 million dollars doing
this I think through a combination of
the sale plus the distributions along
the way but I might be wrong maybe it's
both uh he said he had uh let's see he
spent 10 million building these out and
over the over the years there's about 20
million in distributions from uh that's
crazy so you know kind of an amazing
outcome an amazing return for this guy
yeah yeah I didn't think that these
would be good and then I like met him
and I started learning about him he's a
nice dude too people should uh go follow
him on Twitter how do you know him I
just don't through Twitter I saw some of
it like I've been going back and forth
with him a little bit and then uh he
listens to the Pod so you know he had
reached out at some point
uh Steph talk about this pay
transparency thing this interests me a
lot yeah so in the last couple years
there's been a bunch of laws that have
changed across States I think Colorado
is maybe the most well-known where
companies have to
depending on the state
um disclose certain aspects of a job
related to pay right so it might be a
range that a specific job requires
um also things like even if you're in a
job you can request your band and you
know why you're paid a certain amount
and how you compare it to others across
the company
um and so that's changing it's still
changing it's like very much in flux I
think there's at least a dozen states
that now
um require you to share those pay ranges
for example but this one girl Hannah
Williams she's 26
um so super young quit her job
um she's making like 115 000 a year and
then in the last year has just been
doing the kind of man or in this case
woman on the street and all she does is
she goes up and she just asks people hey
what do you do how much do you make
um but her social accounts have blown up
so she has over a million followers on
Tick Tock again in a year
um 450 000 on in Instagram
and she's on other channels as well and
so an article was written about her in
January and she had already made six
hundred thousand dollars since her
switch and so I'm sure she's made way
more now with the accounts being the
size they are
um but this is one of the the cases
we've talked about this before when
there's like regulation change there's
like a rule change a Line in the Sand is
drawn and then that has implications and
this one's so far-ranging right because
it impacts
any job Within These given States
so if you go to her profile she's doing
a really good job so you go to her
profile and Tick Tock and you click that
link that says Stan so check this out so
here's how she's making money so the top
link is an indeed link where it says get
a job as a nurse and so she's getting an
affiliate thing then she has a market
research guide which is learn how you
should do learn how much you should be
making and I guess that's so she can
collect emails but then click attend and
uh attend LA and NYC workshops so she
partnered with Capital One to do local
of like seminars at their Banks like
because some of their banks have cafes
and then she also has I think I believe
it's a subscription database where you
can see individual salary data packed
with contextual information
this one is awesome this is how you do
it also Sean this is how you doing Sam
uh invested in Stan so good good use of
Stan here for the uh putting a link in
the bio that lets you let you make a
bunch of money
um yeah this is cool we've uh we've
talked about levels that FYI on the Pod
before which was a similar concept which
is like crowdsourcing salary info so you
can if you're an engineer at Facebook
you can go find out am I getting paid
what other L4 engineers get paid or
should I be working at Google and what
would I get paid if I was over there
um I think they're they're doing an
awesome job of this when we had
mentioned this on the Pod somebody did
this for doctors they were like uh we I
think we had said you should somebody
should do this for nurses and doctors
and then they they were like Hey we're
Med students and so they went and did
this for doctors and created a database
I think they got acquired by levels uh
actually after after hearing it on the
Pod uh and then taking action on it so
definitely think that there's
opportunity here and I like
uh Sam what do you call it regulatory
inflections uh breakage
Reflections
inflections is the I word the
inflections which is anytime there's
like a law change there's well there's
like multiple inflections so there's
like a tech inflection which is like
uber exists because everyone now has an
iPhone or and you have GPS in your phone
then there's like
um cultural inflections which is like
teens feel comfortable filming
themselves uh and then there's
regulatory inflections which is uh this
drug is now legal or this patent is
about to expire or you now in Colorado
have to disclose your salary ban
therefore opens up new opportunities so
this is there's another one you have
here that I was gonna say the so you
guys have talked about hearing aids on
the Pod before so as of October the FDA
relaxed their rule which basically meant
hearing aids could be sold over the
counter which is that they're
not sold over the counter it's
like it's been bothering me so
much that and glucose monitors I'm
amazed that they're not sold over the
counter I've been trying to get a
hearing aid and they make me go to all
these appointments and I miss them
really yes another fun fact around
hearing aids which I feel like is
interrelated to the fact that they can I
is it now or already that they can be
sold over the counter is it this coming
up no they can okay so they already can
but
um apparently 99 of hearing aids um or
custom hearing aids uh are 3D printed
already and so there's a few companies
that basically own this Market currently
but the reason I love this is because 3D
printing is the epitome of like Tech
hype cycle started in the 80s then got
way over hyped wasn't ready everyone
thought it was dead but it's like come
back in these really Niche places like
hearing aids we talk to people on Trends
a while ago that were using 3D printing
for like dental implants things like
that and so I feel like it's it's
something that actually is like
overlooked because people were like oh
3D printing is dead wait what do you
Sean you said yep as if you know you
know people doing this for teeth yeah
one of my best friends uh one of my best
friends from college he's a he's a
surgeon and he's a ENT surgeon so ear
nose throat and what he um I was like
well he was in med school so this is
like over the past like you know eight
years or whatever he's been the guys has
been in school forever and uh I was like
how's it going he's like oh you know
it's fine but like I'm having a the most
fun because now I run Duke's 3D printing
uh facility I'm like 3D printing like
just like for engineering like you're
making toys what are you doing he's like
no like the medical 3D printing and I
was like wait I thought Med I thought 3D
printing is like not even a thing for
normal you guys are already using
it in medicine he's like dude I I
surgically implanted part of a skull
that I 3D printed the other day like uh
you know we take your jaw shape and then
we're able to like create like the
perfect shape that we needed for uh this
implant this uh this the surgical
process and I was like wow I had no idea
and they're doing this with like
basically
it's interesting some technologies take
forever to get into medicine because
it's like the high stakes spot and for
some medicine is the only justification
for putting in the time and the money
that it takes to get the technology to
work and I think that's kind of where
where um
uh 3D printing has gone where it's like
it started as like this hobbyist thing
but then the real commercialization so
far has happened on the the medical side
I think the same thing's happening kind
of in VR people are trying to do the
hobby thing for a long time but one of
the better more commercial use cases of
VR is you know doctor training flight uh
you know pilot training
um things like you know you know
imagining instruction yeah exactly
anything where you need to sort of
visualize and and uh plan something it's
worth the money to develop a really high
quality VR simulation because it's
cheaper than doing a real a real uh
prototype of it
I got friends in hospitals as they say
well you're Indian of course
of course you do you're the odd man now
but you know you're you're chilling web
three for years turns out you're a
practical guy as well we put the
blockchain in your brain baby
um yeah do the uh do this well I also
for this hearing aid thing I met these
guys that were doing seven million a
month in sales on their hearing aid
brand that I had never heard of and I
was like oh huh maybe uh this makes a
lot of sense actually like DDC hearing
aids I think that's actually gonna be a
big deal
um was it bootstrapped they I don't know
if they're fully boots yet but like yeah
they're not like Venture act it's like
but they made bootstrapped and then like
their uncle gave him some money to keep
scaling it that's that same like that
sort of vibe
and they were profitable
I mean I'm just turning you on yeah they
were yeah
are they Mormon oh my God how far how
far away from the coast did they live
inland
[Music]
have you heard of HubSpot see most trms
are a cobble together mess but HubSpot
is easy to adopt and actually looks
gorgeous I think I love our new CRM our
software is the best HubSpot grow better
we have two things Sean you want to go
yeah I gotta come clean I have a um like
a very late disclaimer I have to give so
a few episodes ago maybe like four or
five episodes ago we had talked about a
business idea that was like a children's
play Space basically you go there and
you like yeah it's just a place to play
you pay pay membership fee and you go
play with all these cool toys inside
anyways I was like oh it turns out like
interesting business it's a franchise
thing blah blah blah anyways you you
just went there you didn't know anything
about I didn't even go there Ben went
there but a business partner went there
and he was telling me about it and he's
like yeah like you know I was talking to
the guy and here's their occupancy
here's their if that's true then here's
what they would be making
well I went and looked at the website
and uh before and after and basically
meetings like bookings to like inquire
about a franchise got booked out for
like four and a half months after the
Pod and I just want to say I have no
idea if this is a good business or not
that was a estimate that was a single
experience it was hey this that's kind
of cool huh that could make money I do
not endorse this I don't know if it's
good or bad I can't say either way and I
really hope that a bunch of people
didn't go buy franchises of this thing
thinking that uh that I was vouching for
this so I just had to say that because I
saw all those meetings get booked and I
got a little nervous I was like oh wait
this is not a uh I can't co-sign this I
can't vouch for this either direction
and I just needed to say that up front
so please don't uh mortgage the house
and go buy a franchise of this thing did
they reach out to you no they didn't no
I don't think they knew well I don't
think they knew what happened
that MFM effect well and the second
thing is so we have like these sources
wherever like I'm about to talk about
something health related or like I don't
know in your case in that example the
franchise related or real estate related
we have like three or four buddies who
will like text and be like hey we're
thinking about talking about this what's
your opinion on X Y and Z and they'll
kind of give us some insight uh one of
those guys his name's Adam Bornstein I
met Adam because he was like he
basically ran a lot of Tim ferriss's
stuff
and one time he had this conference
called 212 he invited me to go and they
would rent out like the Four Seasons and
one time I checked into my room and it
was so big I called down to the front
desk and I was like hey who do I share
this room with is that it was a 4 000
square foot Four Seasons Penthouse the
presidential suite that had like a
16-person dining table a movie theater
and that's how I met Adam and he invited
me to come to his event and so I've
always asked him for health stuff well
he just had a book come out it's called
you can't screw this up I'm trying to
think of the best way to summarize it
but it's basically so I have this thing
written down it's basically Ryan holiday
James Clear Tim Ferriss like that style
of writing and like that like
I don't know simple hacks but that's
kind of a bad word but I don't mean it
that way but like these simple hacks on
how you can create healthier diet habits
so the book is called you can't screw
this up he also worked with Arnold
Schwarzenegger and that's who got uh he
got to write the forward so I just want
to give a shout to Adam he's a friend of
the pie so I want to give him a shout
out but let's do this jobs of the future
I think this is a good one yeah and I
also love that you're branding this
steps list well done wait a waiter if I
had to I love Sarah's list
um but yeah this all comes from I guess
two things one people think AI is taking
all of our jobs I personally don't fully
agree with that we don't need to dive
into that well what's the effect what's
the official stance at a16z right now is
there like uh
money
do they just like is there like a poster
where it said like web3 is Future and
they just like put an X over it they
just wrote Ai No comments no comments
but
what I'll say is we even on this pod
have talked about different jobs
um that don't quite exist or maybe are
starting to exist I've talked about
Chief automation officers Sean you've
talked about this idea of like a mental
Fitness coach
um and I guess this idea of Steph's list
is partially I want to share a few ideas
today but I also want to hear from the
listeners like what are the jobs that
you think are
as you know some people might say a
little more anti-fragile but also that
again like don't quite exist yet or
early the types of things we would have
talked about start with the stat you
have here because I think the stat
actually makes it clear that these
aren't just like
like oh cute things on The Fringe it's
like no this is the future
yeah so um
of employment growth in the last 80
years
so AKA
between 1940 and today 85 of employment
growth came from jobs that did not exist
in 1940. did they not exist because like
AI didn't exist or did they not exist
because it's by newcom new businesses
like new businesses the job title didn't
exist is what you're saying yep
so even you know simple examples of this
that I think anyone can recognize from
even the last few decades
before 2008 2009 the idea of a social
media manager did not exist the idea of
a ux designer did not exist and those
are jobs that truly like what tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people now do these jobs and so there's
going to be versions of this I think
it's a little more brainwracking to
figure out in the age of AI because you
can almost ask like oh well is this
going to disappear in three years
instead of 30
um but I think actually there's maybe
like Frameworks to think about this so
for example I think drones are kind of
hitting that we talked about 3D printing
hitting that stage where a lot of
consumers own drones but a lot of
companies are also starting to use
drones and so like what within that that
industry could exist it could be like
drone technicians there's a lot of
drones people are going to need to fix
those drones is there like drone traffic
control there's aircraft traffic control
so why wouldn't therapy right safety
inspector charging installation exactly
on your radar for like well let's start
with the ones you ones you talked about
before so you said it quickly but I
think it's worth repeating because you
were on I don't know a year ago when you
said it so Chief automation officer when
you said that at that time this was kind
of like definitely pre-ai being like the
thing that everybody's talking about
um what does a chief automation officer
do and why did you think that was a cool
job uh like a job of the future
yeah so I mean a lot of companies will
have a CTO the CTO typically though is
so wrapped up on like what's our
infrastructure is you know cyber
security what's our our
um
how are we tackling that and how are we
keeping our you know our company safe
our data safe what they often aren't
focused on and maybe some people would
argue this is the role of the CEO but is
how do I actually take the technology
that exists today like AI
um and enable every single person within
my company to understand how to up level
their jobs right so like to become 3x
more productive because most of those
people unfortunately either aren't
plugged into the technology don't have
the like excitement to actually
implement it within their job or
honestly it's just one of those like you
don't know what you don't know okay
Steph can I give you let me give you a
compliment
I remember that pod that we did we
talked about that at Hampton the first
Tire we made was an automation expert
really the very first hire his name's
Grant all he does is automate stuff so
he's basically a zapier plus air table
expert yeah and because one of our
values early on was we want to grow to
be big but we don't want to have to hire
loads of people so let's right away
start automating stuff and it was
because of that conversation so the very
first hire we made was an automation
expert that's awesome and you know what
it is awesome it is awesome the
bottleneck is not typically like you
have to create new things it's that
they're basically you're bridging a gap
usually a duct tape a ton there's a
process we're doing that's kind of
tedious manual repetitive or uh low
value ad but needs to be done and then
there's tools that could do that if you
knew they existed and you knew how to
pipe them together and Stitch them
together so that they actually work and
what this person does and like I do this
at our company almost by accident which
is like 4 e-commerce companies like I
just discovered yesterday there's
somebody who just has to like spend
hours a week just like Square cropping
photos so that they look better in
Shopify from what the photographer gives
them and I was like wait you do this for
how many pictures and they're like yeah
it sucks and I was like you know there's
this tool that will just bulk you bulk
upload and it'll do that and then it'll
put them it'll pipe it to you here in
stock and you can see it you know we'll
use a different tool to pipe it into
slack and you'll see if there's one
that's off because you could just kind
of skim this with your eyes and and then
you'll just be able to fix the one off
that's not good but 98 of them will just
be done well the first time
automatically by this one tool and
they're like oh that's like you
know thank you that saves me a bunch of
time and now I could go do things that
are actually going to drive a little
more growth versus just like some
that had to be done and uh how
many of those are there in every company
there's a ton of those and and the
problem yeah the problem is Sean is even
let's say that hypothetically you only
have 10 people even though you've been
10 people for three years just 10 people
has created enough habit that even
getting an automation persons in now
it's gonna be like oh man where do I
start so doing it with ten thousand
people is like an impossible task that's
why we were like let's get this right
away let's do this right away yeah there
should be like a ratio like for every 10
employees you have you have one Chief
Autumn or not Chief automation officer
but someone who knows how to automate
you just pair them with teams and you
they literally do use their interviews
they sit down they say hey let me shadow
you for a day let me just see what you
do and then from there I bet anyone
myself included who tries to automate
what I can they would just pick up so
many things of like why are you doing
that at all so I think you should also
have this for
um team collaboration have you guys ever
read this book five dysfunctions of a
team
Yeah by Patrick something I don't even
know who's it's a great book honestly I
love that book I think other people's
like a narrative right other people I
think don't really like it's kind of
like Fiction it's a it's a business
advice book but it's written as a
fictional story which is cool because
that's not usually how those are written
it's basically describes like there's a
company you know whatever Acme Inc and
they go to this like team off site and
they're trying to figure something out
and then you have these like four
personalities or five personalities or
whatever and um and it shows the like
different ways that a team can be
dysfunctional and once I worked in a
bigger like you know I've worked in kind
of like two-person teams that's what I'm
in now uh well I I think the takeaway of
the or the what the you forgot the part
where he says the point the reason the
books called that is uh successful teams
all look different but every
dysfunctional company is the same and
here's the five things that they all
have exactly and you kind of identify
them but it identifies it and the way
the book's written is kind of cool I
think it's a sort of like it's it's
here's a situation they have two people
who both have kind of like valid
perspectives or one person doesn't
realize that the thing that they're
saying is causing the other people to
feel a certain way and causing all these
like second order effects
um anyways it's a good book for like
management I guess but what I the I
guess my real takeaway is like I've been
in a bunch of companies where they do
these like it's like
builds up and then they're like we
need an executive coach we need a team
off-site we need to like break down all
this Scar Tissue that's being built and
like dysfunction that's in the team and
resentment that's in the team and what
all these things are not allowing us to
perform at our best I actually think
that companies should embed this in the
company so I think there should be
somebody that floats around
that's basically like the the chicken
billions who's like the team
psychologist or whatever it's sort of
like that but instead of one-on-one
what's her name therapy I love that lady
yeah I stopped watching the show after
season one so I I forgot but uh she's
awesome she's Wendy Rhodes yeah
so basically instead of that it's
somebody that just sits in meetings and
takes notes and every week they just
deliver like
Sam do you know that
you do this and you say this and that
that's making these did you notice that
that makes these people feel this way
and it and when they walk out of the
room you know they're not going to go do
the thing you want in the way you want
because of the way you said it or this
person just didn't have that information
and they were put on the spot maybe you
should put in a process that gets the
information and a dashboard that
everybody sees beforehand or whatever
right like somebody that identifies
dysfunction because let's say for every
10 people you hire if you can make that
team 10 more efficient you've basically
created one extra employee without that
payroll and so I think that the numbers
would the ROI would be there if you had
this but I'm surprised this doesn't
exist so I think that's a kind of a job
in the of the future is basically like a
collaboration expert so somebody that
like is like a internal
um you know Compass team Compass to
figure out like you know how uh where
are they like that word Doula you got to
use that word Doula here yeah I guess
I'll just keep you as a doula as a guy
uh and pissing everybody off Sam what do
you think any jobs that stand out to you
what are you guys hiring for
um
I don't know uh
but nothing that like uh some of the
ones that are like that you see
out there and then I see their titles
and I'm like oh you don't you're not
actually good at that is community
manager it's like Community manager is
like a title that I actually don't think
most people know how to make community
so that's kind of like a nonsense one
here's one from the podcast that we've
talked about like uh we have like a
podcast producer uh Ben Wilson right now
and we have uh you know people will have
like social media manager they have like
all these different functions but what I
told the team was like I think we just
need like a band manager it's basically
like yeah if podcasts are as they get
more successful they're kind of like a
band you have the talent they're the
face they get on stage they perform and
there's all the that that needs to
be done like whether it's like we're
going on tour we want to sell merch we
wanna um like develop this cult
following of fans that just love us
because we just do dope that like
is fan service fan love then you have
the recording stuff that's got to get
done and you kind of just need somebody
who's like a hybrid of a business
manager or an agent as well as like
somebody who's kind of got the community
building skills of a community manager
and that's what a band manager is for
bands and I think that you're going to
see this more for uh for podcasts and
YouTubers is like uh it is a role that's
sort of like the the band management
like the milk boys and whatever they
have that it's like but most others
don't have it underneath them
yeah for sure what are the what are the
what's the what are the lists that you
have here head remote and then cyber
actuary what are those so head over
much dysfunction at companies especially
the ones that transition from being
non-remote to remote totally just copy
and pasted a bunch of things from the
office and they don't actually know how
to build a remote organization from the
ground up how to do things
asynchronously and so it's kind of crazy
when you think about how macro a shift
that is for like you know thousands of
people to be doing things all one way
switching to a totally new way and to
have no like expertise
from someone to actually guide that
um so that's the idea of how to remote
and some companies already have this
like a remote work officer or rwo what
would they do it's like well
people like I know in our company it's
like well first they have to it's kind
of like I.T there's like well they need
to have like a good home setup Sam
you've talked about this like we need to
not look like dog on camera with
whether internally or with our clients
and our customers so like how do we make
sure everybody's got like a good zoom
setup okay secondly like how do we
create some best practices around remote
working and and how to like you know do
stuff that's different now that we're
not all in the office I could just like
look each other and talk to each other
real quick and uh how do we set
boundaries for different time zones how
do we plan meeting you know like all of
that I think is is definitely in
occasion-based Pay I mean isn't this
crazy like to your um idea with Hampton
Sam of the nice background the same
companies that had these really strict
clothing rules like you have to show up
in a suit and you have to look this way
or letting people sit with their MacBook
under their chin with like a dirty ass
background behind them showing up to
their business meetings trying to win a
client and it's like where's your
digital suit you don't like right they
don't care they don't even think about
about that because it's so outside of
their field of view but that's just one
example and I think do you guys do that
at a16c because like when I imagine a16
they're like that's a khaki pants that's
a khaki pants type of place well
I don't think we have a clothing code
but we do have like Lululemon's ABC
pants is like the official pants of men
here's something that a16z does do
whenever like put together as related to
this but like their design team will
create every quarter of these beautiful
Zoom backgrounds that the company uses
and they actually look good you know I
feel like a lot of Zoom backgrounds are
like the company's logo kind of
awkwardly like photoshopped in the
background and it's just like around the
corner
um and they again they refresh them
every quarter everyone has access to
them so there's at least that visual
consistency
um but I don't know if we have a
clothing code but I hope some of your
bosses and employees listen to this and
I just want them to hear me say this it
is me and Sean making fun of you guys
not stuff
like a threat there that was awesome
you're like it's like on TV with like
put the camera on me put the camera
play on me and you look down the barrel
and you deliver some like wrestling
promo that's what I thought you were
about to do but you were trying to cover
Sam's version is like look at me and
he's like you're great
No One Believes In you more than me
I
I had a friend that lived in China and I
used to like text him all the time and
I'd be like dude your government sucks
what's going on with that and that I
would reply with by the way whoever's
reading this it is me saying this not
him
[Laughter]
don't disappear my friend uh
invest in the cool Zoom backgrounds and
stuff you know they got the uh I think
what like 700 million in management fees
those management fees got to go
somewhere so I'm glad they're putting
them to good use
yeah
um but I mean just to summarize on the
head of remote thing think about I think
maybe the easiest way to think about it
is there's all these macro Tech Trends
right like remote work AI automation
cyber security right like the idea of
like a chief security officer didn't
exist like 10 years ago right because
that just became such an important
um I guess concept within especially
Tech firms so and what's this food
engineer one
well I wanted to ask you guys about this
because yeah we never talked about this
Hannah do you guys remember that yeah I
know
concept of like a food engineer
will exist I think this one's a little
further out so give this story Sean yeah
so uh a lot of people know David
Friedberg now because he's on the all in
pod so he kind of got a lot more more
popular or famous but uh this awesome
guy I used to work at Google created
this thing called the production board
which is his like kind of incubator
startup Studio whatever and they build
things that are kind of like hard tech
so it's like uh things that interface
with the real world they have like
Hardware they're making food or making
you know biological you know substances
or whatever like they're creating real
world things and uh he had this company
called Canna that he created that was
basically like the coke freestyle
machine in your kitchen so you would
have this device this Nespresso machine
that sits on your countertop that can
make like a thousand different drinks
exactly to your specification using
basically like the equivalent of a
printer cartridge so it's like you put
in this cartridge that's got all these
like micro flavors and then you hook it
up to your water supply and it's like it
just takes water it makes it cold hot or
bubbly and then it pipes in the exact
dose of flavor to create whatever drink
you wanted you want tea here you can
make hot tea you want uh sparkling water
that's like flavored like you know
Blackberry boom done and so it was this
awesome idea because it will also be
good for the sort of like the world in a
way because a lot of the supply chain is
basically spent bottleing water or soda
putting it in cans putting it on shelves
putting a cardboard around it
transporting it to the store
transporting it to your house then
transferring the the trash to the dump I
was like dude what if we just took the
water spot everybody already has to
their home and we let you make whatever
drink you want very cool idea
um and then out of nowhere just suddenly
got canceled and they were like yeah
unfortunately to scale up we needed a
lot of money and uh you know in this
funding environment we couldn't do it
that's a excuse who can't raise
I mean I mean they've got like the top
Tech podcast yeah in the world
um yeah they also maybe an interesting
way of framing that idea was also it was
it came from the idea that they had done
research and they had realized that
basically every drink out there whether
it was tea whether it was wine whether
it was beer 95 water like not just 95
water but even the chemicals that go
into it I don't remember the number but
it was something like there's only three
like 30 or so flavors that you need to
basically generate every taste
um but yeah I don't know maybe something
yeah we should get him on our tweet at
him I want to know what really like not
what really happened like there's a
scandal but like tell me more because
clearly he could sneeze and raise 30
million dollars for an idea so like I'm
surprised if it wasn't like it must have
been that sneeze his sneeze will be
lovely flavored too I mean I I feel like
he must not have believed meaning like
the team must have realized it's not
feasible or something like that or they
must have proven that the thing is not
feasible or non-economic in some way
for them to not be able to raise money
because just on the concept I feel like
they could have raised more money
um so so I think you know that's uh
that's an interesting one what went
wrong but he said that he was going to
send us one and then like his assistant
or someone at the company was talking to
us and they just quit no not said this
one they were like we want you guys
basically their idea was like if you
could make any drink flavor on the spot
okay then what happens to drink Brands
and his idea was like drink Brands
become software so they just become
Brands yeah yeah we would create a drink
flavor you know uh Sam's you know uh you
know Almighty root beer or whatever and
it would just be like a specific dosage
of flavors and that somebody could just
buy it for a dollar on their own Canna
machine and it would just like dispense
the drink and we would make money for
every one of those like flavors sold
basically every one of those drinks sold
um that was the the kind of the concept
so they wanted us to make one and they
were like come down to our facilities we
never got around to doing it and now
it's gone
did you guys see the freestyle machine
for condiments yes I did see this dude
sign me oh yeah sign me up dude this
stuff is it's have you been to like Hot
Pot in Asia where they have the sauce
bars no tell us that as well if you go
to Hot Pot in Taiwan like they're
literally there will be hot pot's like a
like a style of food or like a yeah yeah
it's like so basically you get a big pot
of hot water
um they give you broth of a certain sort
and then you basically go shopping on
this wall and you you pick oh I want
some like some noodles I want some like
beef whatever and you pick it out and
then you basically cook your own soup
but as part of that they have rice and
other things and they have they
typically have this huge sauce bar of
like maybe like 20 to 30 different
things like like garlic or Ginger soy
sauce like ponzu sauce whatever and you
make your own sauce and so when I saw
this coming I was like this is genius
because like this is exists in Asia but
only in these like hot pot occasions
right yeah I I kind of love this I
really do want the future of food to be
a lot more interesting I think I think
it's going to be you have so in your
jobs thing you got food engineer I got
that one
um cyber actuary what does that one mean
did you ever explained that one Yeah so
basically I mean a lot of people even if
we relate this back to AI are worried
that like you know there's just going to
be a lot more cyber quote-unquote crime
right people like replicating your voice
like getting your bank details and I
think this idea of being a cyber actuary
is basically
actuaries assess risk for anything right
um how risky is it for us to deploy you
know this celebrity's voice in this way
how risky is it for us to
um I don't know like open source our new
llm like there's going to be all these
implications of things um I guess be
becoming a lot more online if they
aren't already and so this idea of a
cyber actuary is like there's already a
ton of actuaries that figure out how
much Insurance should cost in you know
the typical world like if you buy flight
and I think there's just like this huge
white space around
um risk that people have not calculated
yet did I tell you guys about Eden data
no
yeah so I met him because he's joined
Hampton his name's Taylor and he I don't
know if he was playing up to my ego
stuff but he told me he created this
because of an article that one of us
wrote on Trends I I don't know if that's
true or not but he launched this thing
called Eden data and uh in just two
years it's now doing like six or seven
million dollars in revenue and basically
what they do is if you are a smallish
startup so like 50 to 100 people you
have to have a certain type of
compliance in order to sell software to
Enterprise companies and so the service
that he provides is and this is like an
oversimplification but there's basically
like a 50 to 100 Point checklist of all
the things that you need to do
and a lot of these startups that can't
afford a full-time Chief security
officer and so instead they pay Eden
data eight to or seven or eight or ten
thousand dollars a month and he's got a
team of outsourced people overseas who
goes through your website and goes
through your entire like the checklist
and make sure that all 50 or 100 things
are done and they have like templates to
do it and then they stay on top of it
and they monitor it in case any changes
have to happen so now you when you go
and Pitch like this Enterprise company
to sell your software and even though
you're a small startup you've already
done all the stuff that needs to get
done and and I think it's I think it's
only two years in I think he's gonna do
eight million in Revenue this year
um and it's like a service that's it's
subscriptions it's like a subscription
consultancy almost and he's killing it
it's a crazy company with huge marches
damn
yeah when I see companies like this I
think like I'm in the room you're
talking to somebody that was doing this
so I wanted to do this for rich people
it was like just overall security audit
for rich people and uh like everything
like your house security your bank
accounts security or crypto security
like just somebody who's gonna come in
and try to uh
like just poke holes in your stuff and
at a certain dollar amount of net worth
like it definitely makes sense and
you're not the expert
and you have more to lose than you have
you know than the cost of the service
like you have a lot more to lose like
asymmetric downside basically and uh I
think that I've reached out to tons of
people I've reached out to tons of
people doing it and the problem that I
saw is that a lot of them for some like
they're all like ex-military guys too uh
and so like I remember I was talking to
pop I was like pop uh after the show I
was like what do you do for security
like can you walk me through it he goes
oh I got this guy named Chad we do this
this and this and then I talked to Chad
and it's a little bit mom and pop yeah
it's not like just like I can just log
in and you can just tell me what to do
or it can just get done you know there's
no like plaid or whatever that other
software where you like you just log in
with your bank accounts and it just does
what you need to do it was very much a
manual process and it was like 15 grand
and like this person's gonna do this and
so I do actually agree with you I think
there's a star I do think this is like a
um
fragmented that's it's a fragmented
service and I think that one great
company can can do all this all the
stuff you need to do let's hit some of
these other random Trends you have
um uh don't mention the one I wrote
don't mention because I got something in
that space so don't mention that one but
uh do uh do some of these other ones
let's start with a mouth tape
yeah so mouth tape
I first heard about this like six months
ago because some guy on Twitter was like
I taped my mouth shut every night for
the last six months the best thing I've
ever done the hot dude the hostage deep
guy will not stop so aggressive with it
uh we have this guy who's got a company
he called hostage tape and it's just
tape for your mouth and he told me he's
gonna launch it and I'm like this is
dumb and then six months later he's like
five hundred thousand dollars in sales
yeah I'm like great and then he's like a
year later two million dollars in sales
and he's like just rubbing it into my
face I don't think he's an official
sponsor but Andrew huberman has been
talking about it and we uh in my
household we like to call him father
Drew as a joke but if father Drew
promotes something and then age yeah
he's like people will buy it bro Oprah
in a way in a way like if he says uh Bro
Science Oprah if he says it's good he's
gonna you're just gonna get a huge Spike
yeah so that's I mean these are just
like I don't know where this goes I
don't know what opportunity there is
other than going and selling some mouth
tape maybe rebranding it but that's one
Trend this guy's company is called
hostage tape and like I saw I was like
oh this is the worst this is the worst
thing ever like this is awful what do
you do but he's privy that was your uh
weight loss idea remember wasn't it
called hostage yeah
SF right kidnap you and just don't feed
you for four weeks
um you should partner yeah
this guy's crazy so whatever kudos to
him yeah but um I guess we didn't even
mention do you guys understand what's
good about mouth tape like what it makes
you breathe through your nose and
breathing through your nose is better
for you than uh breathing through your
mouth
so Public Health haven't you been
talking about this being forever for the
last year I just I went into a
I don't know all the American Grocers
the high protein Bean yeah so it's got
dude you've been talking about this to
me forever you keep telling me about
this Bean I've been out with you a bunch
of times is that more protein than
chickpeas two percent or two times more
fiber than edamame 80 fewer calories
than almonds 60 fewer carbs than
pistachios 35 grams per serving
obviously they cherry pick this data and
compared to like the the best option
um for them but these beans I think
they're like originally from Italy or
they're popular there
um but I just have seen this over and
over and over as someone who traveled a
lot where like edamame
edamame was not popular in North America
20 30 years ago like no one knew what it
was right it came from Asia and so now
when you go to restaurants it's like a
very very short
how would you like to invest in The Next
Step
Sam do you remember when Bobby at
hustlecon um would go around pitching
people to joke and he's like his picture
no I thought it was hot dog water it was
tuna water
dude the uh have you guys had chickpea
pasta of course I don't like it it makes
you fart like crazy man it makes you it
just it'll give you the number three
seven forty percent of many calories as
almonds but 70 more gas it's like that's
the Lupine uh you know pitch
um okay so you've been calling this for
a little while I see I mean this seems
like a good like d2c product idea to be
honest
um there's like one company doing it um
this one or whatever
yeah brahmi they also do I think the
chickpea pasta
um but I just think maybe there's
something in the supply chain or like
how hard it is to you know procure this
stuff but to me they're they're pretty
cheap they taste really good you eat
them plain
will they at least this company will do
flavored versions so they'll do like
rosemary garlic or does it give you gas
I don't think so I didn't do an A B test
so you're gonna well you can admit
I don't think they did it's a safe space
it seems like you can say it Sam farts
every episode
okay all right I'm gonna buy something I
like this idea yeah I'm gonna try these
out and see uh see how I feel about it
um by the way this is the type of
product that when we say on MFM there's
going to be 13 people that start this
for six weeks and then yeah nobody six
months later we'll be doing it for
whatever reason it's like and the same
people that tell us they're gonna come
back in eight weeks and they're gonna
say actually what do you think about
this idea yeah yeah yeah it's like if my
DM history has four different ideas from
you that you were pitching me for
investment like it's probably not going
to work out it's a no forever exactly
you've got the forever forever no oh
yeah
I'm still on that line This is a no
forever
let's do can we do one more around these
Advent calendars because I feel like
that's another case where like I've I
don't know someone in the community is
going to jump on Sean do you even know
what admin though is this some like
Catholic what is this oh yeah this
is this is as Catholic as as Catholicism
is advent advance in December so uh so
we Catholics I'm Catholic are you
Catholic stuff no oh heathens sorry
the camera oh yeah
you're not one of us but it's okay uh
the we have lent which is like 40 days
and that was when like Jesus like walked
around in the desert you're not supposed
to eat meat and like that and then
we have Advent which is the 30 days
leading up to Christmas and oftentimes
there's an advent calendar where it
tells a story about like what Mary and
Joseph Jesus's parents like what they
did like with the donkey and the mule
and how they got like all these gifts
from people whatever it tells that story
and each day you open up the calendar
it's like the kids favorite thing
there's a piece of chocolate in the
calendar
yeah I'm sure you've seen the Advent
calendars like at some point it was a
religious thing then capitalism got
involved and then you know every day
kids are opening a little chocolate I
swear myself I thought the Advent
calendar was those little calendars that
are like you peel it and there's like
you peel the calendar for each day oh
yeah yeah I've been walking around
because that's what an advent calendars
with it for for a long a long time my
whole life I would say
this one you like peel back it's always
chocolate inside that's the idea usually
that's when you get it like Target or
whatever and yeah it's like a couple
dollars but it's like the most simple
you know you you buy it for your kids so
what's your idea here Seth
the better Advent calendar
five minutes yeah
no so this comes from I Gotta Give this
guy namazaki Paul
um
he doesn't sound like a Catholic no no
no no so this is it I don't think this
has to do with religion but I actually
got this for cal
um this past year because here's the
thing Advent calendars yeah I guess it
was tied to religion but they happen
around the holidays and so people are
scrambling to figure out last minute
like what should I get my family as a
gift that's kind of thoughtful but fun
and a lot of people get Advent calendars
but they get these like shitty versions
that are like you know expired milk
chocolate from the year before
what Paul did is he created this socket
calendar and so if you click um that's
the best way to celebrate Jesus's birth
too
yeah
we're basically every day for the month
of December or you can use it after you
open your little Advent calendar but
it's not little it's like
it's like the size of a printer kind of
thing
um and you get this like special sake
that he has hand-picked from Japan this
is partially like his job his existing
business
um and he sells them for 300 bucks and
every year he sells 500 of them which he
caps and you do the math that's like 150
000 just from that one
one drop for him and he doesn't get that
much traffic like if you look at his
existing site it's like 2 000 visits per
month so not something he would
typically be able to make much money
from
um but that's one example that just got
me thinking especially since we're like
What six months ahead of Christmas what
Advent calendars is the my first million
Community what are you gonna make that
is way cooler than the expired milk
chocolate I mean I've seen some stuff
like hot sauce calendars Lego calendars
um but it's got to be something that
like someone can open either for 12 days
because some people do the 12 Days of
Christmas or all of December
I this is actually cool yeah I actually
think this is a this is really this is
really cute and cool and awesome
um you have a picture of this person who
has a binder full of condiments like
individual packets and I see your vision
here and this is actually cool I see I
smell what you're stepping in and I
think it's awesome well this so the
Tweet you're talking about Sam what is
that phrase is this girl Nicole Nicole
who says her tweet just says organize my
sauces and it's like do you guys
remember you know if you collected uh
like playing cards back in the day or
um coins they had those binders yeah
with the little I don't even know what
they're called but this tweet got 468
000 likes
um I think it's probably one of the most
popular tweets of all time and it's just
her organizing her sauces from around
the world
so these are not for use this is just
like collections that one is for a
collection I feel like the Advent
calendar it would be for use
yeah wow this is crazy
what I like about you Steph is like
you find things that I would just scroll
by but you're pretty good at finding
interesting things and applying them
like connecting to like five other
things yeah when I scroll past something
and I think this is stupid you write
that thing down and make it sound smart
it's amazing I waste my time curating an
Evernote that it's just full of random
internet but but what you do
something that's different is you
actually remember it so I like bookmark
so much stuff and then I just like
forget all about it you actually
remember it and then you like
it's just the difference between like
good and great in terms of like whatever
the skill set is that we have you like
actually are organized that the you know
what makes someone good versus great is
like being organized you are very very
very organized with this stuff and that
actually helps your like thought process
I would think when are you um
dude when are you just gonna bail and
start creating some of this stuff
like you yarded this train
S I was working at a company
here at that company
said and I must have been what 24 or
something 20 yeah around that I was like
next this is the last job I all have
right like after this I'll go and do my
own thing but then ever since then I
just get keep getting offered really
cool stuff that I was like oh I get to
more money well I get to be paid to like
go research Trends and go down these
internet rabbits
acquired now I'm at HubSpot and I get to
build this like cool Creator program
okay great and more money
now I'm at a16z I got to
get to I got to be this interesting
person with more money in my pocket it
was amazing
yeah
you're learning this receptionist
sitting there she's like how could I get
the things that are in their bank
account to my bank account
she's three years old and she says this
thing where she goes this is my best day
ever like and I'm like she might
actually be telling the truth this might
have been like the best day ever like
this is the one and that's how I feel
stuff is whenever she gets uh a raise at
accz this is my Best Day Ever guys
Steph you and I were talking about like
how much money like you've had like
you're like we were going through an
exercise of like at 20 we had this at
23.
you've had a nice run you've had a very
nice run a very very nice run compared
to where I came from so yeah like you
were saying earlier Sean if like 21 year
old me would have said yeah like this is
where you'll be this is how much you'll
make these are like the opportunities
you'll have yeah it's pretty wild are
you even 30 no oh my God what would uh
what would 200 year old you say like
what would the reaction be well it's
funny because I would I feel like I
still have
like throughout my whole life because I
didn't grow up very wealthy a very like
money orientation not that I need that
much but just like oh my gosh like you
have that much money like go buy a car
like go buy nice clothes go you know go
like use the money that you've always
wanted but never had but it's funny
because now that I have more money I'm
still like just as cheap as I ever was
so I don't know if that stuff ever
leaves you Sean did you know that
Steph's uh half Ty are you Ty my mom's
from Taiwan yeah do you know that no I
didn't know that
there it was supposed to be super
special or what why are you telling me
this at our old company when someone
found that out and I was like yeah I
mean I I could see that there was like
people like Steph why are you lying to
us you're Canadian I've had some well
Canadians not I know that was the joke
they're like quit lying yeah why are you
lying about being Taiwanese Jordan was
like there so there's a huge Spectrum I
don't know why like what it is about the
way I look but some people when they
hear that I'm half asian are like oh
yeah of course like I knew that and then
other people are truly shocked um Jordan
was one of those and he went to Sam or
no he asked me and he was like does Sam
know this
[Laughter]
the way you look uh it's just like what
is their level of exposure to different
races versus anything to do with you
um yeah yeah by the way this uh you're
this think about being cheap I read uh I
was reading the story yesterday about
this guy who um made a bunch of money
and uh they're like what was your first
purchase he goes I hired a consultant to
help me spend money and he goes uh you
know I had learned over 25 years how to
make money it took me a long time to
learn how to make money and I was just
very honest with myself that I have no
idea how to spend money and uh I could
shorten that learning curve if I get a
coach to help me spend money what was
this coach called a wife ah
I'll be here on
you gotta learn to spend it's like it
takes reps what was the coach actually
called
I I mean I don't know it's just like I
don't know his actual job title but you
know a spending consultant let's call it
I have no idea but what do they like
teach you how to do I think it's I don't
know I mean he didn't go into details on
exactly what the guy said but let's just
pretend for a minute that he did I would
imagine he does two things one is
um figures out where your psychology is
screwed up about money because
everybody's got like this it's like you
know people like body dysmorphia I think
everybody has bank account dysmorphia
too like uh you know you think you need
more money than you need you even when
you have money you still act like you
don't have money and like you it's like
all this like weird stuff it's like dude
you're fit now why do you still think
you're fat like you know you have to
sort of like retrain yourself to see
something different in the mirror I
think that's part of it like just just
talking to figure out what are the ways
your your brain is a little screwed up
about money let's identify that first
some people spend too much some people
don't spend at all and then I think the
second thing would be like all right
what do you really want so uh let's try
to outline your like dream lifestyle or
your you know the things you you really
want identify those and then let's
calculate like okay how much those costs
could you afford those now could you
afford a step in that direction and like
giving you the encouragement to pull the
trigger on the things that you actually
want or setting certain rules like you
have to spend this much per month what
are you going to spend it on and like
also on the protect your downside so
it's like hey we're going to set aside
this amount of money so that you're like
safety reflex is satisfied like we agree
that logic biologic this amount of money
being here untouched means you're safe
okay cool so now we can talk about this
other spending part without triggering
your like fight or flight mode around
your fear of financial safety
yeah I want to look this up I need one
of these things uh yeah you should look
it up I don't know I don't know if this
exists maybe it's a job of the future
I don't know if uh is
roommates early podcast episodes would
Escape
millionaires who are fretting about
eight dollar blueberries at Whole Foods
or like I remember one episode where
this guy was like I think I had at least
10 million dollars and was picking up
like a stroller on the side of the road
um things like that where it's like
clearly like yeah you haven't upgraded
your thinking or your mindset to where
you are dude I just made 400 selling
used gym equipment from uh from like
from some stuff I'm not using and I'm
like this is my Best Day Ever 100 bucks
yeah
my best day ever like it's like I feel
more happy about that 400 that I do
making much larger sums yeah uh and the
best part is that I paid 300 for it five
years ago now I got 400 and it's like
the best high I read this thing that was
like um this guy timer who created he's
got this company called causal and uh
it's like this Excel competitor but here
he has this blog post I really liked
where he was like
he was trying to figure out in a nerdy
way how to decide if he should buy
something or not and so he's like um
he's like well I break everything down
into kind of like I don't remember the
the exact message but it was something
like this it was like the frequency of
like how frequently am I gonna get the
benefit of this and then like what's the
like magnitude of the benefit and so
he's like something that's
it doesn't have to be a big shift but if
it's gonna happen all the time or like
10 times a day or something like that
like you know like I bought a phone case
that just feels better in my hand and it
was like a great purchase because like
the hand feel of my phone is something
I'm I'm touching my phone all the time
and just making that feel a little
smoother a little better was like dude
what what's that case called by the way
I'm looking very good uh let me look at
my hand feel so it's um do we know how
much it costs yeah is it going to be
free plug for you guys moaz I think is
the name of it but it's got this like
this is not like plastic feel so this
feel right here is like uh it's almost
like the feel of a basketball it's like
a almost like a like a like a traction
kind of like feel because I was like I
hate the plastic feel of cases
um like I think that feels cheap and uh
and and I don't enjoy it I don't want
the leather ones either so I was like
what else is there and found that and so
he he identifies like if you're gonna do
it if it's gonna be frequent then the
magnitude needs to be less if it's going
to be infrequent then the magnitude of
the joy it brings is going to need to be
high and you can kind of multiply those
two together to figure out like the
value of that item and then you sort of
say okay that's the value to me and then
what's the price to me and you sort of
use that to figure out you know where
should you where should you spend versus
not and what people mostly get wrong in
that is they under count frequency so
like a better pillow or something like
that is great because you're going to
sleep on it every single night versus a
nice bad Louis Vuitton bag that's gonna
sit in your closet like my wife's bought
a Louis Vuitton bag and she literally
never takes out she doesn't want to get
messed up it's like wow that's the you
know most expensive you know six
thousand dollar thing that just sits in
a closet for no reason
um versus things that you get joy out of
all the time and so I bet if you guys
looked at like what's the best purchase
you made or you're you're most satisfied
with this year it's probably something
that you interact with somewhat
frequently or it was like a one-off
life-changing experience that was just
like crazy magnitude
yeah
what was that article called I want to I
want to read uh I need some good money
therapy in my life money therapists
yeah yeah I need some good money yeah
send me an article but Steph
um
appreciate you doing this you're always
coming with fire your your Twitter
you're a Twitter person still right
that's better person's Seth Smith IO
go listen to the a16c podcast we're
doing some cool stuff there that's just
what it's called a16z podcast right yes
all right we appreciate you thank you
[Music]
thank you